now uh breaking news on coronavirus and
the uk health security agency is raising
concerns about a newly identified
variant which the agency says is the
most challenging yet uh let's find out
more about it uh either bennett joins us
from the newsroom so tell us about this
new variant uh what's it been called and
where does it originate from
yes thurman well there is a high level
of concern within government tonight
around this new variant because as you
say it is the worst scene so far it
doesn't have an official name yet other
than
b11529 and i should stress there are no
known cases of it within the uk and only
a handful
of confirmed cases elsewhere three in
botswana where it originated at 3 in
hong kong and 53 in south africa which
is where it's
spreading most rapidly and that is why
tonight the government is actively
considering imposing travel restrictions
on arrivals
from south africa
now the concern comes from the fact that
the variant has multiple mutations
around 30 which is twice as many as the
delta variant some of the mutations have
been seen before others are completely
new which is what's fueling this concern
there isn't that much data or evidence
for the scientists here to go on yet
particularly around vaccine efficacy
against this variant
also on transmissibility so for that
reason the variant hasn't yet been
deemed a variant of concern but we have
been told the world health organization
is meeting with officials from south
africa tomorrow so um we believe a kind
of an official name for this variant
will uh follow shortly um
now while i said there aren't any known
cases here in the uk one can't be 100
sure of course because not everyone is
getting tested so for that reason the uk
government is now
contacting anyone who has arrived from
south africa in the uk in the last 10
days it's believed to be between 500 and
700 a day and asking them inviting them
to get tested in order to eliminate as
much risk as possible of importing this
variant and it's spreading here